media is the only business where
marketing and delivery are the same so
think about this if you had let's say a
show like Joe Rogan Joe Rogan's
marketing for Joe Rogan is his delivery
for Joe Rogan which is one of the ways
that media creates even more leverage
because if you think about from
operational perspective you can just
have one team that does all days
focusing on marketing expanding the
audience pumping and Drilling and
pumping and drilling it's getting you
new people and the more people you get
from your marketing the more eyeballs
and ear balls you sell on the back end
through sponsors and endorsements now
we're not doing that but I find it
really really interesting to think about
that is that there's no other business
where the thing that you market and the
thing that you sell are literally the
same